[Music]
foreign
the Press preview our first look at
what's on the front pages as they arrive
so it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the political editors of
the Daily Mirror and the sun on Sunday
John Stevens and Kate Ferguson very good
evening to both of you
um and they will both be with us from
now until just before midnight so let's
take a look then at what's making those
front pages and the financial times has
word of the German government green
lighting the export of leopard 2 tanks
to Ukraine with the aim of bolstering
Ukrainian forces ability to defend
themselves
the guardian leads without story as well
their headline Berlin agrees to send
tanks to Ukraine in historic move
Telegraph describes it as a hammer blow
for Vladimir Putin
the Metro carries the results of a study
which found communities in the north of
England have received substantially less
of the government's leveling up funding
than their southern counterparts
the express carries a warning from
pensioners groups of the chancellor
against a treasury plan to increase the
state pension age again 11 years earlier
than expected
the mirror leads with the Fallout from
the Zara Alina murder case and the
failings of the probation service
another warning to the chancellor in the
mail that he needs to come up with a
plan to grow the economy after the
country's debt hit two and a half
trillion pounds
and the times also reflects on today's
economic news that growth prospects have
actually declined ahead of the budget in
March
and the star raises the Specter of
Chinese technology turning off fridges
laptops or even doorbells into spine
devices for Beijing
while the sun tells us about production
difficulties on a game show spin-off of
the hit drama series squid games
and just a reminder that by scanning the
QR code that you can see on screen now
and during the program you can check out
the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us
so let's get stuck in with John Stevens
and Kate Ferguson then a very good
evening to both of you lovely to see you
both
um a number of different stories on the
front pages I noticed today but um John
there is one story that has led a few of
them and that is what appears to be an
imminent decision by Germany to actually
send tanks to Ukraine having
prevaricated for some time it's let's
show The Guardian first of all with
their lead headline there
yeah so this has been the story as you
said it's been kicking around for the
last few days and weeks and Vladimir
zelenski has been appealing to the
Westford tanks he's been saying that
Ukraine is about 300 tanks if they're
going to have any chance at defeating
Russia their concern the Russia is
planning a spring offensive that they're
going to try and take more territory and
countries have seemed to be dithering on
this decision and part of this is
because the ukrainians have wanted these
leopard tanks which are made in Germany
and then they helped by other countries
in Europe places like Poland but one of
those restrictions on them as part of
the contract when Poland bought them it
said that if you wanted to export them
again you'd need to get permission from
Germany and Germany's been hesitant to
do this they've been concerned that they
don't want to just just be Germany and
European countries acting they wanted to
kind of act in lockstep with the us but
it seems we're finally getting there we
heard at the end of last week that the
UK is going to send about 14 of their
Challenger tanks and then today the news
that Poland's going to send about 14 and
Germany is going to send about 14 and I
think just before we were about to come
on air there was news breaking in the
U.S it looks like they're going to send
about 30 tanks I think it was and it's
just counting up the mass of that I
think that's about 70 tanks which is a
quarter way to 300 so nowhere near there
yet but hopefully it will make some kind
of difference their efforts to defeat
Ukraine that's to beat Russia yeah and
and looking at the Guardians report here
they reflect on some of the reasons that
perhaps Germany has been dragging its
vks they're saying that the
groundbreaking decision as they put it
by Germany ends months of painful debate
and soul searching and we'll put German
tanks in use on the battlefield in
Europe for the first time since the
second world war and and if we turn to
the financial times as well they also
reflect on some of those
misgivings among some in Germany about
the risk of escalation where they
descend tangs do you think those
arguments have had any sympathy amongst
other allies
wow the short answer to that is probably
no I mean I think most viewers and most
allies of Germany will be thinking why
has it taken so long why are they
githering dragging their feet what's the
point of producing these tanks in a NATO
power in a western Ally if you're not
willing to arm a country when they're
under siege by a cruel dictatorship like
Putin but but as you point out in those
headlines is actually a huge move by
Germany because since the second world
war Germany stayed way out of all
military business in Europe and the
world they have this Covenant on their
tanks which means we can sell them to
you but you've got to get permission
from us before you can export them
elsewhere they've been incredibly wary
of anything that could be seen to kind
of Ratchet up military
um tensions or or maneuvering in Europe
and that is why they've wanted to be as
John just described in lockstep with the
us but I think this is a huge story
tonight finally we've seen Germany
historically move on its refusal to send
tanks to other countries they've
announced today they will or they're
going to probably formally announce it
tomorrow and that means lots of other
allies lots of other countries can now
send their leopard to tanks to Ukraine
John pointed out that Ukraine are going
to need quite a lot of these tanks to
make a real difference in that war but
it's still a huge step change in the
kind of military assistance we're giving
well that's right and and John you
mentioned the fact that there's also um
reports tonight suggesting that the U.S
May well confirm that they are sending
their Abrams Tanks as well and they've
been reluctant to do that hadn't they
they were Keen for Germany to send its
tanks but they were saying that the
Abrams tanks are very big unwieldy and
difficult in terms of the of the uh the
maintenance if you like they're fuel
hungry as well so there were plenty of
arguments being made by the Americans as
well against sending their own tanks
yeah I mean I'm no tank expert from but
from reading about it it sounds like
they're much more complicated to operate
the reason they particularly wanted
these german-made leopard tanks is
they're much easier to train or much
easier to kind of get sent over and
start being used uh quite quickly but we
have seen quite a step change if you
think right back to the beginning of
this war almost a year ago remember in
the UK was first sending arm supplies
and you saw the diagrams of the flight
paths and they're having to fly around
Germany because there were concerns that
germs didn't even want these kind of
um defenses going to Ukraine even
through their airspace we have kind of
seen a massive change from there to
where we are now however it does seem
that every stage during this war the
West has been quite slow to act so I
wonder what difference it would have
made if the West had been much better at
arming Ukraine before the Russians had
started their Invasion you're nodding
their case I mean the other issue as
well to be to be born in all of this is
is the issue of presenting a united
front Russia would potentially want to
capitalize on any kind of Divisions
within the allies
yeah I think I think John was making an
interesting point though because
obviously the reason Germany is so
reluctant so reticent to send military
equipment and Aid to other countries is
because of the memory in the history of
the Second World War but obviously what
we're seeing now in Europe is the first
major war in Europe since the second
world war by another brutal dictator who
represses his own people and wants to
repress and Conquer last ways of Europe
if he was given the chance so you know
you have to balance up that history
which um you know it's it's very clear
and well documented why you'd have an
uncomfortable history of militarization
in Germany with a totally changed
context now yeah your point is totally
right about the united front you know
NATO the West have wanted to create uh
present a united front all the way
through and you know what broadly we
have but what this decision weeks too
and the cold hard fats of it is that
this war will be warm because of Tanks
because of guns because of soldiers not
because of sanctions and that's where
the West really has to put their money
their tanks their Weaponry where their
mouth is and arm this Democratic country
to stand up for itself and its borders
against an undemocratic country so
potentially a big story tonight no
confirmation as yet that may well come
tomorrow on these various tank
announcements and let's move on then to
um some of the other stories around and
the Metro has taken your interests and
John at the their front page story is
All About leveling up and they say it's
Grim up North so why are they using that
headline
yes we've had a lot of leveling up in
the papers in the last couple of weeks
last week we had that announcement from
where she's doing that which didn't seem
to go terribly well there were a lot of
areas that were quite angry that they'd
missed out on the cash and obviously
when Michigan went to go and make the
announcement he filmed that video in the
back of the car without wearing his
seatbelt and we're hearing more about
leveling up in tomorrow's papers there's
a big Gathering taking place in
Manchester the convention of the north
which is a gathering of politicians and
business leaders you're going to see
Michael Gove the leveling up secretary
his labor opposite number Lisa nandy
making speeches there people like Tracy
brabin a labor mayor in the north Andy
Burnham lots of figures out tomorrow
talking about investment in the North
and the story on the front page of the
Metro is some figures from the ippr and
they're saying that if the north was a
country and you compared it to other
countries in Europe it would have a
lower level of private and public
investment then every other country
apart from Greece and I mean these
figures have been slightly fiddled in
that they're not looking obviously the
north isn't its own country you are
they're not including London's figures
there so they are slightly out of Step
but I think there is a feeling here it's
kind of building on this feeling from
last week that perhaps not all the
places that should have been invest
getting investment have been getting
investment and remember back at the
start of back at the last election in
2019 part of the reason that Boris
Johnson did very well in lots of places
that haven't voted Tori before part of
that was brexit but part of that was his
promises on leveling up and saying these
people hadn't had the proper attention
that they should have got before and
that the toys were gonna do that they
were going to transform these areas I
think there's a real risk at the moment
that partly because the toys haven't
managed to kind of deliver on their
promises partly because of other things
save the economy what's happened with
coronavirus and Ukraine that I think a
lot of people when they go to the
polling stations next time might look at
the local area might look at their High
streets and they will ask themselves is
our area better off than it was at the
last election have the Tories managed to
improve it I think a lot of people look
around and see a lot of closed shops a
lot of projects that haven't actually
taken place and I think that's going to
be a difficult message for the tourists
to sell to voters well yeah and there
will be a lot of examination Kate
weren't there over fairness and whether
the money's going to the right areas but
there's a report on the front of the
guardian and which suggests that
whatever money is being sent to these
areas is also being squeezed by
inflation basically people have less the
councils have less spending ability
because of the high costs going up
yeah there's two slightly different
stories and they're both speaking to the
same point which is leveling up agenda
this one in the guardian is talking
about the fact that those leveling up
bids that have been successful those
pots of money that different councils
and areas of bid for and pocketed well
those projects are getting more
expensive why are they getting more
expensive because of inflation
everything's getting more more expensive
so you know that
30 million pound pot of money you might
have got to redo your High Street
through your train station or your
shopping center well suddenly you'd
budgeted for kind of
pre-massive inflation project and now
you don't quite have the money to cover
it and that's what this Guardian article
is speaking to the fact that even
successful leveling up bids now might be
fast running out of cash I just wanted
to bring in here the ippr report which
Jordan talked about which is on the
front of the Metro because I think it's
quite a fascinating issue really it
speaks to an issue that all governments
grapple with which is for a long time
actually If we're honest over 100 years
large parts of the Midlands large parts
of the north have lagged behind the
South and the southeast in terms of
wealth and productivity and every
successful government has promised to
try and turn that around we know about
Boris Johnson then is leveling up agenda
but before that you would have had Tony
Blair's new author communities before
that you had John Major and Thatcher and
what they did in Liverpool and the
docklands and I think it this speaks to
the heart of the problem for this
government which is
how are you going to somehow leverage in
private sector investment and get Rose
going and that's the big issue for the
government
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me tonight John Stevens and
Kate Ferguson and uh Kate we're talking
to the Daily Telegraph next and um a
small news in brief on their front page
about Nadine zahawi I don't know how
relieved he might be that he's not
splashed across more of the front pages
again today but um what is this little
article here saying about the
controversy of his tax affairs
so this is an interview Lord Evans has
given today he is Chairman on the
committee of sorry the Committee of
Public standards and he's criticizing
Nadeem Sahari for his use of aggressive
lawyers so you're re and your listeners
and viewers will know that if Nadeem
sahari's story has been rumbling on for
over six months now really it was first
reported that there were questions
raised about what tax he paid back in
the day when he sold up you gov whether
or not he had dodged or avoided paying
tax because of a complicated share
system thing that he used and most
recently obviously we reported
originally in the sun on Sunday that
he'd settled that dispute with hmrc set
um coughing up Millions to settle the
dispute
and that includes a reported 1.2 million
pound fine now what Lord Evans is saying
here is that over the past six months
when he's faced those questions that
screwed me about what tax he paid when
was he under investigation what was he
settling with hmrc he was being simply
too aggressive in his use of legal
letters to both journalists and
investigative I guess you'd call the
researchers tax experts who online were
delving into this as well and he's
raising the point that if you do go into
government you're going into public life
you expect higher levels of scrutiny and
that's not really consistent with
Penning quite aggressive expensive legal
lessons Okay and in the meantime the
government's ethics advisor of course
examining whether or not nothing to
hurry broke the ministerial code we've
got 30 seconds John I've got to whiz you
on to the Metro
um Irish eyes are smiling why are they
smiling very briefly
they are smiling because the Oscar
nominations were out today loads of
people from Ireland are on there the guy
from normal people goodness sakes I
can't remember the list of the rest of
them
you were searching for there anyway
we're out of time